foreign
to be here
raise your hand if you've ever felt like
you're the only person in the room who
didn't know you were doing
okay great so I'm not alone
so if you're like me you feel like
somehow someway
everyone else deserves to be here
but you on the other hand you have
somehow some way
snuck your way in
I remember feeling like this when I
first came to Stanford more than in any
other time in recent memory I felt like
I had
Bamboozled someone for the school to let
me in I mean why would they choose me I
got them off the wait list
the more people I spoke to the more I
realized I was focusing on
what I was not
some of the conversations I had made me
feel really small
surely you must be an Olympian
no
not that okay
um or a Grammy award-winning opera
singer
no
okay okay then you must have built and
sold your first unicorn before your 19th
birthday
no
I exaggerate the only slightly to
Showcase how I was perceiving some of
these interactions at the time and while
I loved meeting such incredible people
and they really did I was doing what
many of us know to be imposter syndrome
for years researchers from psychology to
education have studied why so many of us
no matter our successes continue to
battle with this mindset
imposter syndrome was holding me back
I was spending so much energy posturing
trying to prove I deserve to be here
rather than doing the work that I came
here to do
insecurity had led me to tell myself old
stories
when I thought of myself I was anchoring
to the version of me that I had been
when I was
14 years old
the one who built herself Concept in
terms of every mistake and misstep
rather than the growth and the strength
built over time
the story I told myself was that I was
forever that kid on the outskirts of the
social scene the one who had a slouch
from growing too tall too quickly who
rocked a back brace and orthopedic shoes
and to had a lisp and a Mumble
simultaneously
that version of me lives squarely in the
before part of the hero's journey story
trip
my internal self-perception looks
something like this
focusing on all of my weaknesses
in my magnifying glass Amplified them
John Didion says we tell ourselves
stories in order to live
well to a degree I loved telling myself
these lowball narratives I mean who
doesn't love a good tearjerker
the Heartbreak the Intrigue the twists
the takeaways and Lessons Learned
and in a weird way telling myself these
narratives felt good
because they were familiar
I was getting myself a familiar crutch
that made risk aversion okay
I could then point to an opportunity
a person a challenge and say
of course that's out of my reach I'm all
the way
down here
today too often there is a dream gob
our background dictates what we think is
in a realm of possibility
where we grow up who our family is what
we know
so when dreams come
getting that job on Wall Street writing
that book starting that talk show we
tell ourselves
there's no way
that's not possible
not for me
we put the successes of others
successes that we secretly want for
ourselves on a pedestal
that pedestal gives us an easy out
we Elevate these dreams and these goals
beyond their actual components to the
point where they are laughably
Out Of Reach
but what if
we take those people those dreams those
goals
off of their pedestals
now I'm not going to pretend like all of
the butts and the asterisks they put in
our minds are made up
society as it stands is not an equal
playing field
resources are not evenly available
still the last thing we need to be doing
is taking part in widening that Gap due
to our own preconceived notions
and took me a lot longer to realize that
even though I wasn't an Olympian or a
Grammy winner I still had a lot to offer
so how did I do it how did someone like
that
the Goku 14 year old
go on to become who I am today
to move internationally alone
to become president of my dream Business
School
to co-found a company
and how can you do it too
we can Channel a better truth
we can become better storytellers and
what's more we can become tellers of
better stories
I looked at who's good at telling
stories
if you study actors you'll find that
some of the best ones are incredible at
channeling truth when it comes to
building authentic characters
what does it mean to Channel Truth
actors can put themselves in a place of
more authentic emotional expression by
thinking back to a time when they felt
that emotion in its most raw form even
if completely unrelated to what they're
currently experiencing the scene
they can then channel That Emotion to
present as a more honest and real
version of themselves
and it's still them
at a different reference point in time
but it's still them
that made me start to think
I realized that that's what I'd been
doing for years before this most recent
vitamin security struck
channeling truth is essentially telling
yourself a story
one that you've already lived
the hard part is in thinking back to the
details of that experience
those details can expand or contract a
memory in almost any way that we choose
let me give you an example from my own
life
so when I was in the eighth grade trying
to figure out what I was trying to say
took expert level listening skills
not only did I have a lisp and a Mumble
but when I was excited I would speak a
million words per minute
and then nod vigorously expecting the
other person to respond
on average it would take me
three maybe four tries before the other
person had any idea what I was trying to
say
public speaking therefore was my Everest
but I knew that it was a mountain that I
wanted to conquer
so what did I do I started small
incrementally small
I might not be able to give a speech
right now but today
I can raise my hand in class without
rehearsing exactly what I'm going to say
okay that wasn't so bad I can speak in
front of a room of people
I might not be able to give a speech
right now but today
I can take a larger portion of my group
presentation
okay
that wasn't so bad
I can handle attention while standing in
front of a room
and not pass out
so far so good today as well uh
in high school I joined modern United
Nations I started giving one minute
speeches twice a week each time I took a
risk I lean on the memory that I had the
last time I'd done something scary
I told myself the story of a different
version of myself over time one that has
built up a repository of memories they
can use to redefine what I'm capable of
by the time I graduated college I was
selected to give the graduation speech
for all of honors candidates and now
here I am speaking to you
the magnifying lenses under which we put
our lives are powerful
we can tell ourselves stories that look
like this
highlighting all of our strengths all
the positives
or even realize that everything that
we've experienced in our lives has
brought us to where we are today and has
value get rid of the magnifying glass
altogether
we can build the skill set of telling
ourselves better stories over time like
any muscle
when we focus on action and take little
risks
it can become our superpower
over time our minds can become Olympian
level resilient
we might not all be unicorn Founders
right now but today we can take a step
towards whatever that dream is
this practice creates data points of how
much you can return to question our
outdated narratives when we focus on how
much we have learned and grown and
therefore how much more capacity we have
imposter syndrome loses its power
I want you to become tellers of better
stories
tell yourself stories that focus on your
strengths your accomplishments your
perseverance
start building muscles towards the
version of you that you'd like to be
face your doubts and fears
everyone feels them
but then move on to action
Channel Your Truth your best truth fully
align into that role
it's not always easy
but if you keep at it you'll find that
you're more capable than you ever could
have imagined
What story do you want to rewrite
[Music]